hi Michael welcome to the show what's
going on man sup fellas how they go
buddy
it's good to see you we're promoting
before you came in we were mentioning
that Europe your your live podcast is
going to be tonight at the grommet I saw
it this morning when I was on my way to
work that you have you're doing that lot
have you done it live before I've done
it live
[ __ ] live podcast at the at the Gramercy
Theater 9:00 p.m. it's gonna be it's
gonna be good fun we talk a lot of [ __ ]
it's gonna be some special guests and
I'm excited and excited to see you see
you guys did you really do I didn't know
you you started I mean I know you're
your mom and dad I didn't know you
started stand-up at one point oh yeah I
was a stand-up at uh when I was 19 I
first I first started out as a stand-up
and and I was alright I was I was I
could talk a lot of [ __ ] I didn't I you
know I was 19 so I didn't really
understand like the idea of a set and
what's up with the mics man yeah you
tried it keeps falling down right
[ __ ] rinky-dinky [ __ ] here yeah it is
we complain about all the time but our
producers the other rooms that better
the other rooms have better mics I'm
just telling I did start off as a
stand-up and and like I said I was 19 I
wasn't that good I could talk [ __ ] I
could in agitate the crowd and and you
know I could keep it moving but I was so
young I didn't you know my thing with
stand-up comedy is that when I had jokes
that worked I didn't want to do them
anymore I didn't understand like a set
right or like a like I didn't have any
like plan I was like if this is funny
why don't want to keep trying to do it
anyway I was 19 I was I was at my
dumbest ever you like really rough he's
not funny anymore because I already said
it cuz I'm cuz I'm the next Robin
Williams in Andy Kaufman I'm so creative
it should you only live once but yes so
that's that was my thing when I was 19
then and then when I started acting that
was like the thing that came most
natural to me well do you do theater and
stuff to me no theatre that I've done
it's one play I've done one play did the
redundancy kill you know I liked it the
play I did was really good I liked it
like III enjoyed that part of it um but
I can imagine you know like your
stand-up your your dope stand-up
and you know I can understand how the
redundancy but then you know like if
you're like Chris Rock or somebody
really good you know I guess it takes
like that skill set to like have your
[ __ ] down so you know I would love to
maybe try it again now I have a more of
an understanding of it and more to say
and more to talk about and just and the
other I'm sure so when you start acting
like there's a lot of ass kissing and
acting like there's not that many actors
I don't believe that that there's a lot
of ass kissing I don't know many a talk
[ __ ] especially when it was young I was
young when I was young I mean it's not
something I mean everything has changed
as far as talking [ __ ] and and
expressing your opinion in odds of
because of social media
uh-huh so so everything is changed but
yeah I mean I guess there is ass kissing
in anything I mean you you know in this
day and age you could get ostracized so
quickly deservingly or or not
deservingly because the social media
right you know and and and twitter has
become a place to [ __ ] tattletale on
everything and and and obviously there's
good for that your there's good things
that have come out of that but it's like
now like you know I could be like well
[ __ ] saying the last time I came on your
podcast Jim was in here you were talking
about Jim Nora and saying that I would
never do a [ __ ] show about him and
then I could tweak that and then next
thing you know I break you guys up
you know I'm saying it's like it's like
you know Twitter now's like you know we
could talk there like I could be like
well twenty years ago um you know I met
you Jim at the [ __ ] Comedy Store and
you know he said you know he called me a
hook nose Jew and the next thing you
know Jim's like what the [ __ ] yeah I
mean it was weeks ago
like half the problem is the Twitter
tattletales but then the other half of
the problem is that people read
something on Twitter and it's gospel
it's it's it's sure it's more powerful
than if you say if I say something to
you that's one thing but if you read a
tweet than some other person right and
it's and it's totally true the tweets
true that you know the tweet is totally
true and and it lives forever so I mean
but as far as the talk it [ __ ] like you
know me in this book this book has balls
and you know sort of embracing like you
know like who I've always been in terms
of like sharing it with the world it's
come from the podcast and then you know
like doing your
I mean you're doing your show the first
time in like doing like all the sport
shows yeah you know that that's like you
know become a forum just where I'm like
sort of people have gotten to know it me
personally and then you know in the
latter I was at the last four years and
then the idea to write a book but now
I'm like yo I'm 47 I know my skill level
as an actor it's gonna be what its gonna
be
III work you know they feel I believe
that you know I mean for me like talking
[ __ ] like like I you know I when I'm
talking about Donald Trump it's it's one
thing but the majority this stuff
particularly book it's all
tongue-in-cheek it's all it's all
breaking balls it's all snapping it's
like it's really just like what we do in
real life and what I say and what my
thoughts about mostly it's mostly sports
although I talk about the play Hamilton
and my love for Real Housewives you know
like it's really like just like what we
say I say to my friends or in my head in
my thoughts so it's you know sorry you
you and you had kind of gotten I have to
Ellen to click you feel like yeah that
would be if the if it was in the reverse
I mean obviously it would be well the
picture of Ellen last week and I have
nothing against Ellen like I like that
I've been on her show she's cool
whatever um but like it was we were in
such a tenuous sort of you can say more
than you ever have been able to say in a
form whether it's this show podcast
tweeting Facebook where the [ __ ] you you
say it snapchat Instagram story story
story story Friendster
friends every [ __ ] place MySpace and
then and then so the picture of Ellen
last week she she had a picture of her
with her wife and she's she's staring at
Katy Perry's boobs tits
funbags right now anything yeah what
else
but Tsongas yeah that's really good and
she said something about you know I want
to wish Katy Perry a happy birthday some
some some bring out the blues and I'm
like go if that had been because the
thing that happened with Cam Newton the
the Carolina quarterback really bothered
me because I didn't think anything of
and they'd [ __ ] drag that
[ __ ] for 36 hours yeah and I was
like if that had been a guy that that
had been me if it had been anyone if I
said that had been Howard Stern if that
had been for anybody any dude that put
that tweet out they would be dragged if
it had been a black dude public lynching
right public [ __ ] lynching so I'm like
you know if we're gonna like if women
want equal rights and eat the Equality
and they want no you know I would say
I'm not talking about Harvey Weinstein
[ __ ] but if you want to equal rights you
don't want to be googled and you don't
want you know stories to be written
about your nipple piercings and all that
[ __ ] then it has to be both ways like
who's to say like if I'm sitting there
holding my wife's I got my arm around my
wife and I'm staring at Katy Perry's
tits and I go yellow Katy Perry happy
birthday let's bring out the balloon
[ __ ] would be like yo like whoo
you know so what a scumbag they would
they would ya be done and if it was like
let's say that was LeBron James you
[ __ ] black [ __ ] drag this
[ __ ] guy
public lynching that's the end of that
so like I already got tried to though
they totally jacked but but Cam Newton
like like the thing with the Cam Newton
thing and I don't listen sports like I'm
a fan of sports and and and and as much
as I hate the Patriots
everybody loves Rob Gronkowski he made
he's made jokes about 69s in front of
female reporters and people laughing
although that's crunk being Gronk the
Cam Newton thing where he you know
questions or a woman's I mean they
dragged him yes and I not sponsors these
lost sponsors anything for me is like
I'm like that could be anybody anybody
it's like none of us are holier now none
of those are righteous
none of us don't have tweets or or a
Facebook or a comet that we've made at
the Comedy Store or or on a [ __ ] uber
or or any [ __ ] place that that we you
know like if you if you if you if you
just from me getting waking up greeting
my doorman getting a coffee and making
it over here to your show if people
[ __ ] were monitoring everything I did
I'd be in [ __ ] prison
well happy jail that's the problem I
always have with it is when we like we
out each other and we scroll to each
other yeah no one's willing to give up
their own text messages like if we're
gonna judge somebody else's I'm fine
with that let me see your phone you show
me your phone and then we'll see if you
have their exactly but they don't want
to do nobody none of us no [ __ ] body
is holier than thou and the ones that
are like the most tightest and the
biggest finger pointers I mean they're
usually the ones that are the biggest
scumbags anti-gay mike pence
type [ __ ] you know like he's
the worldwide leader in in in hating you
know every all things gay so and that's
just that's just a big party so that I
don't mean how the [ __ ] we got on there
we got on a talking [ __ ] yes and and and
Alan Ellen and you meant and there's
also things like we're like with the
whole lot the Harvey wines sometimes the
information coming out is good like with
Harvey Weinstein is doing right now
Kevin Spacey like I don't know are you
here everyone knew he is gay who gave a
[ __ ] but this other stuff it's like wolf
like you hoped for his sake that this is
just some dumb isolated thing hate you
don't think so you think I have not
heard have you heard listen I have heard
[ __ ] yeah nothing like like nothing like
within my reach just innuendo and yeah
I've heard things I've heard things I've
heard things he I've heard things
nothing like first hand but just things
but it's like I always go back to
Whitney Houston because when the rumors
first came out about Whitney Houston
being being a drug addict and God bless
Whitney Houston and she had a rough life
but she was so like at the time again
this is in the in the late 80s and 90s
before social media but you were like
there's no way we didn't use crack and
look if she's [ __ ] beautiful like
she's clean-cut and then you know now is
I remember for years but get the [ __ ] at
it no come on Whitney Houston Whitney
and then it came out but in my opinion
listen every single person every star
there's not one star who hasn't been
accused of being gay from Will Smith to
Brad Pitt to Leonardo DiCaprio to Eddie
Murphy to ever all of them through every
every single person in Hollywood has
been accused of being gay accused you
know whatever the word is interesting
less you mentioned by the way every
single actor every single rock star Axl
Road Mitch I mean everybody if you're
that big you're gay yeah oh he's never
been accused of being gay I've heard
he's been Koosman um yeah but I prayed
he would be like every single person has
been accused of being gay how did we get
on this so the accusation say yeah I
mean no so the Whitney used to think so
but then when it found out like she had
a severe drug problem and obviously
there's no jokes in that because her
life was tragic and the rest of her
family's life has been tragic and the
daughter not so but it's like you know
when there's when there's smoke from in
my opinion when there's smoke a regard
to these rumors
around celebs nine times out of ten
there's fire and I mean the excuse the
apology we were talking about it before
that came out where he goes like you
know I don't remember this incident and
even if you're gonna give him the
benefit of a doubt and say like okay he
doesn't remember if a fourteen-year-old
says like he he had me down on a bed and
you're like yeah I don't know maybe I
did it doesn't happen once and you
forget about it you know what I mean
there's not be a lot of 14 year-olds I
play devil's advocate for that the thing
about all this [ __ ] is why don't you
call why don't you tell your parents now
once you tell the cops why is it Twitter
why is it Twitter it's like 30 years of
your though outside this this kid was 30
years ago thinking I know I'm not yet
I'm just saying like some of the some of
these allegations with with the Harvey
Weinstein and I'm not defending this
[ __ ] guy cuz apparently he's really
was on to rape [ __ ] yeah but like why
are you telling the head of Amazon that
Harvey Weinstein raped you why aren't
you going to the cops if you're if
you're comfortable enough telling
another person in Hollywood that this
happened you should be going directly to
the cops unless they think that like
these guys are so powerful they got the
cops in their back pocket this isn't
[ __ ] what is this game of Thrones
what is it ray Donovan no cops in the
back pocket they just had itíd the
[ __ ] guy there's no cops in the back
pocket this isn't you know the fun like
you know the Jack Warner days you know
with Mary come on man I don't know why
you do like I don't know why you go to
them and not them maybe she did go to
the cops and there was nothing they
could do maybe there was only as he said
she said maybe they told her look
there's no evidence other than your word
against his and there's no I don't know
if she did or not but the problem with
that was that Amazon did nothing I think
I think that was what it was that god I
know and didn't do it I know they lose
any I don't know how I'm supposed to
talk about my [ __ ] book you say what
you want to say which is really
refreshing especially now when people
get in trouble for and then you don't
care about that you're not worried about
that
and I meant about the ass-kissing to
like most people who have a book to
promote right and a career to think
about right are not gonna call out Ellen
on Twitter's right because they're
trying to get back on Ellen I certainly
won't cuz I've never been on listen my
[ __ ] wasn't disrespectful it was it was
a big picture about Ellen if I never get
back on The Ellen Show I'm on the Jim
and Sam show right here in Sirius XM you
know I'm saying so like
I know where my heart is and I know
where my sense of humor is and I know
where my point of view is yeah are you
surprised at the the podcast took off
like it has hell yeah I mean I'm
surprised that my podcast is taken off
you know because when I started my
podcast like I was literally I was doing
it by myself in the room and like I
remembered what the first time I was
like I'm talking to myself into a
microphone in a room and and so yeah I'm
surprised and I'm also surprised you
know it's funny because my podcast host
G moody and again we're gonna be at the
Gramercy Theatre tonight 9:00 p.m. yes
ether suits are fought by the Bensons
[ __ ] that's an amazing place for a live
like Gramercy the everything about it
it's an intimate place yeah it's it's a
[ __ ] great place for a live show I
can't wait but but my best friend
literally since I'm 12 who's a funny
dude I've always known he's funny and
you know people that are funny that ever
but they've never done anything in
entertainment and then one day I was
like I gotta record the practice like
he'll come on with me just let's talk
about basketball like talk some [ __ ] and
he was just very comfortable doing it
and the fact that we're doing it
together to me is crazy because we've
literally been doing the same thing
growing up sleeping over at each others
house riding the trains playing
basketball going to and from basketball
games and just hanging out since we're
12 so that to me is like the most sort
of bugged-out part that you have a
project now you can do with a guy who
isn't quote unquote in show business the
and it's a good thing that you love your
buddy with your friends yeah and the
shit-talking is really just like you
know because you know like the chemistry
you have like you guys have a chemistry
like the rhythm yeah that you have with
somebody like it's rhythm like it's like
it's like if we are like it could be
whether you're playing basketball like
one of you is playing guitar want to use
playing drums it's like you either have
that organic natural rhythm or you have
to learn it and and we obviously we have
that like you know he can tell when I'm
talking and pausing and vice-versa and
all that [ __ ] there is a weird thing
when somebody plus a rhythm is a great
way to play sometimes then you start
talking and somebody who knows you
understands that and it's like with
people making fun of each other
everybody's being funny and joking and
there's a rhythm and there's a weird
flow and you can't prove it in court and
it's hard to describe what it is and you
don't even notice it's there until some
clod jumps in and [ __ ] I know exactly
what you're talking about
but that's exactly it right you don't
know until somebody wrecks it oh yeah we
had a really fun thing there and so that
[ __ ] dope right [ __ ] blundered
again right right yeah it happens it
happens all the time but you're not
worried I like the fact that you're not
worried have you had anything come up
with you like your name is popped up a
few times in social media has a rabid
anything like oh did I [ __ ] up their
[ __ ] I said that yeah there's been a
couple of things that have been
misconstrued where my my intention was
wasn't articulated clearly but there's
not anything that you know I mean
there's a couple of things that I think
we misconstrued it but it was also like
you know it sounds [ __ ] funny but
like tweeting something if you're gonna
talk [ __ ] and and you sort of known at
this point like that you're gonna talk
[ __ ] is a skill set like you know you
have to want it's it's actually it
sounds crazy but it's actually like you
gotta like use the words concisely
directly so you can't articulate so so I
haven't had any trouble now I've been
having trouble not nice to any real
trouble I had some [ __ ] with that fat
[ __ ]
from ESPN's and Leba [ __ ] it's whatever
it's a it's sooo boring to get into but
but but but that wasn't like that would
be sort of the only trouble that sort of
instigated from Twitter but based on
based on your description of him as a
fat [ __ ] [ __ ] you know he's on there and
it's like a cuban minstrel show but
other than that you know it's cool yeah
you don't care you're not worried about
him getting you and hurting your career
or anything that's fat [ __ ] yeah because
don't necessarily have a sense of humor
about themselves especially with
somebody who's not an athlete right they
don't like people making jokes about
them you know what the the only person
who I think could misconstrued well not
misconstrued the only athlete that I
have any sort of personal thing and I
have utmost respect for him as an
athlete and also as a most person I most
respect from as a leader and somebody
who's used to celebrity in the right way
because I think you could talk [ __ ]
about somebody and also have tremendous
respect for them
Braun like to me what to halt
yeah after in here twenty three reasons
why LeBron James will never be like my
but if you read the book two twenty
third reason in my opinion is is the
most genuine part of the whole chapter
huh and and and you know not to skip the
whole thing but I say and then after
breaking his balls for like four pages
very in great detail yeah I saw one of
them was because you want to get
attached to the new Space Jam you can't
even find a franchise you want to be
like but but in my opinion the thing
that LeBron James has done that's more
important than any of his basketball not
basketball big three
you know ring chasing [ __ ] is that
he's been a great outspoken star and
star athlete his is is is the way he's
you know dealt with you know social
issues racial issues you know his
tweeting out calling Donald Trump you
bomb you I was jealous at at like that
was like that was good so he's been very
and I think he's inspiring other
athletes like you're saying in terms of
getting in trouble like to take a stand
say something yeah and because he's the
biggest star right and he's a corporate
brand and he's always but he's been like
and he doesn't do it necessary like me
where he's [ __ ] you [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
but but but he does it in a way that's
very honest very hard-hitting and to the
point and out of all the things that I
think about LeBron as a basketball
player and and like you know dissing my
kids when I tried to introduce some to
him at the all-star game play did he do
that yeah yeah yeah yeah that's it sort
of inspired like my like when I said
like any athletes that out personal that
was the one thing I was like you
[ __ ] did you know him or no no I
knew him ya know it was it was I don't
know this is before I started like even
doing sports he was rude to me read but
I had already met him but more important
was rude to my kids in front of in front
of me and it was blatant and it was on
purpose
What did he say to your kids it was just
it was nothing he turned his [ __ ]
back to me and to my kids they don't
want no pictures they don't even want
pictures they don't want selfies and I
give him a pound you could just give a
smile that's it right really the kids is
really shitty yeah it was it was
something with me and it doesn't make a
difference but listen LeBron James is an
icon and he's a tremendous star
knowledge it so in in the chapter I talk
about that stuff with the kids I break
his balls about stuff you know on the
court off the corner on sir but at the
end of the day I think he's been a
fantastic celebrity because it takes to
be that famous you know inserted like
going back to the beginning like you
know what are you what are you willing
to give it up give up what are you
willing to sacrifice he set the tone for
all the other young athletes to be like
yo you you can say something and you can
do something and you you should use your
form for good he did he but I've also
heard he's not nice I only met him once
and he was ok to me because we had a
mutual friend but I saw him in a UFC
event once and everybody there is nice
and he was rude he was rude to Bob Kelly
and I saw him like blowing people off
and I think even Dana spoke about it
like you don't come here and be rude to
our fans like I think he's but he's got
a reputation just for being [ __ ]
that's what I've heard probably is you
know and on his in Annie's defense when
you're 6 foot 9 and you're LeBron James
and there's no hiding you know how it is
gym [ __ ] you know some days
might not be your deed like there's no
hiding if you're LeBron James right you
could put on a hat you could put on a
hat like you me I could go onstage and
you know like so when you're that
recognizable every single day of your
life where you can't go into a [ __ ]
coffee shop you can't get gas you can't
you're almost a prisoner that's true
that I have compassion for cuz you know
like and it's it's a slippery slope like
forget forget all these guns I'm just
saying like it could put you it could
put your defenses up so do you feel the
same way about Kaepernick in the sense
that he almost like had to eat martyr to
himself
right the end of his career pretty much
so he's no the players I don't think he
knew that but I mean [ __ ] look
Kaepernick's journeys is is you know
just at the beginning in my opinion you
know because I got that nice million
dollar book deal he got the new million
dollar book Tunney he made a lot of
money playing football like Kaepernick's
not gonna be hard up for money mean like
25 I mean these money is his money he'll
make money speaking to hell the other
guys
the thing about the kaepernick thing
it's is again like you know we're in
such a time where it's like you know
he's got a book that everything is on
Twitter but it's like he's not even 30
years old like his story and his journey
right and and and the impact of colin
kaepernick
is yet to be determined in my opinion
yeah you know i think i think and he's
think he's you know i think he's putting
his money where his mouth is in terms so
he does a lot of [ __ ] like we don't see
him on social media we don't we barely
see him and I think he's doing a lot of
stuff like he's being an activist
low-key like you know he's in the
trenches so in a guy like that he
doesn't any guy like that a lot of times
it's the reaction to something that
either makes or breaks right like he was
doing what his conscience said for him
to do I have a problem with it um and if
people have just said like hey look I
don't agree with it but he can do it it
wouldn't be a big thing today exactly it
would be a couple of guys doing it not
to be the end of it but because they're
like don't you dare wait and then it and
then it dip down and then trauma brought
it back to life and then it turned to a
whole other [ __ ] thing you know
music Trump just brought it back to life
so that people wouldn't talk about
Puerto Rico as much well when he brought
it back to life it was before the the
storm in Puerto Rico I I thought about
that I was like did this [ __ ]
that devious that that that he was like
knowing if he said like I wonder if he
look over here planning can anybody be
that sort of like he's not like he's not
like a goddamn he's not like who's the
UM you you'd call her up for from so I
mean I don't [ __ ] know I I don't know
I mean but I know that he revitalized
the whole sort of talk of it and the
conscious of it and you know it's gonna
it's gonna be what its gonna be with uh
with Kaepernick and I wish him all the
well like I mean he's a brave dude and
he didn't back down and you know talk
about the consequences like that was
like he's not gonna play football again
do you think you will play again or no
hell no I think I don't know it'll have
him not it's [ __ ] up cuz he should
play football he should have been like
at least a backup quarterback for some
team for sure how many years did he play
I think five six he's young yeah and
they say this guy's was worth a worse
quarterback rating yeah like
great but he wasn't the worst yeah no he
would have definitely had a job like
there's bit like there's backup
quarterbacks in the NFL right and like
there's third string quarterback like I
mean he and and also the P means so much
to the players now like I think he's
good for a team I think he's good for a
community like you know it's like the
you know like he's like whatever I
actually think this point it's it's it's
definitely not happening I think he's
probably come to terms with it
and you know like I said the stories I
think it's he you know he's writing a
book and I'm curious to see what it's
gonna be but you know I think it's only
like he's in at least 20 something years
old when you realize that you could do
this podcast and make money and you can
make money and do live shows and like
you can you can make your living just
being you
right talking [ __ ] but does it make you
want to act less like I has this acting
stuff is for the birds no no no I'm
always gonna want to act and I'm acting
as my first love and it's my passion
and this other stuff is too but like
I'll always need acting like I'll always
need that forum it's it's made me it's
made me II I appreciate both because you
know like the thing of like you know
sort of being myself or like you know
like just like you know you know like
that sort of business of being myself
either you know to me like there's a
thrill of that too like there's an
artistic merit in that too and like
whether it's live shows or which I don't
do a lot of we're doing that in New York
I'm not a stand-up comedian you know
we're you know that's a IIIi have such
respect to him but like you know like I
love doing it like I love doing it I
love the podcasting I love talking about
supports I love it yeah you know because
as much as I love acting like my dream
like and it's never went away like
there's still a childlike thinking me
like when I'm around you know athletes
I'm like oh [ __ ] like I when I go to a
basketball game and I've been to
hundreds of basket Williams I'm always
like one of the first people in the
arena like I'm always like hyped to be
there like it never goes away so like to
be able to have a forum to talk about
sports and the way I do it and not take
myself seriously because it's sports and
especially with all this more serious
[ __ ] going on the world there's [ __ ]
sports you know like and Sports is such
a safe haven to have
that sort of love and hate it's silly as
hell but like you know like the hate
that we have for the Red Sox oh they
hate that we have for the Patriots it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] but it's a it's a good
place to have so when they start
kneeling and it becomes political are
you like this game Muhammad Ali
yeah Muhammad Ali wouldn't be mentioned
he'd be just another fighter if he
didn't if he wasn't you know if he
didn't you know take his stance you know
uh there's so many different athletes
Kareem abdul-jabbar Jim Brown there's
there's there's so many different
athletes that have made political stance
Ali being the the biggest and and and
most well-known he would just be another
boxer so didn't see the thing about it
right now with the kneeling it works
when you know people like it when it
makes you comfortable people like it in
hindsight when it's you know 78 year old
Muhammad Ali but but when it's happening
and it's making you uncomfortable they
[ __ ] these athletes and you know it's a
great way to put it people like it when
it's in the hindsight yeah but when it's
making them uncomfortable because people
a lot of people loved Frazier and they
did despised Ollie back then right he
was not here right first came out he was
I mean talk about Kaepernick I mean mom
at least probably one of the people that
I know the most about he was what was
his original name 60 whatever years I
know so much about ollie 1961 you know
black Charlie listed in the sixties
taking these stands these radicals it's
like now it would be crazy like if
LeBron James came out talking the way
Ollie did now it would be nuts imagine
what the [ __ ] I mean the reaction back
then they were like who the [ __ ] do you
think you are at Elijah Muhammad yeah I
mean he was and you know and and the
thing about Ollie's like if you look at
his old interviews at first he was
saying things that were in culture and
they weren't palatable and that he the
thing about Kaepernick and about all of
us going back to this Twitter thing it's
like we're allowed to grow and evolve so
if I say today bla bla bla bla bla and
and it doesn't really make sense and
it's sort of out there I am allowed to
as a person to be like you know what
that bla bla bla bla bla that I said
would Sam and Jim is now this you know
and it's like I've changed my opinion
my perspective my whatever yeah you know
you might get better it might get worse
but it's like Ali when he first came out
like some of the [ __ ] that he was saying
was way the [ __ ] out there and and and
his biggest fans didn't agree with but
but but that doesn't mean but I mean the
whole thing about race and all that [ __ ]
it so we're comfortable being
uncomfortable having these discussions
and so we're until we're comfortable and
acknowledging like yo I just makes me
uncomfortable we're not gonna get
anywhere like like race is supposed to
be uncomfortable right it's not going to
be fun it's not gonna be easy to fix and
and you know and it's never going to be
easy to fix and and and and until you
acknowledge that and be like y'all right
we're gonna get in this pool and and you
know whatever it's gonna be it's gonna
be anyone to us I can swim right no it's
just a hindsight is a great point
because you think about all the people
who get mad at the Kapernick stuff stuff
and the black life Matt black lives
matter stuff like imagine how pissed
they would be if Muhammad Ali was doing
what he was doing then today you were
like can you imagine crazy how pissed
they would be if he was doing that I
mean Jimmy you know you're the biggest
hourly fan ever like can you and I do
like him can you missed people would be
they would be very upset although I
think even back then though taking a
racial stance in 1960 something I'm such
a big fan but you but you know I mean
with especially going to Elijah Muhammad
and the Nation of Islam ik talking [ __ ]
as Cassius Clay was one thing and being
pretty and I'm gonna beat you in three
but [ __ ] all of a sudden guys I'm not
going to Vietnam no yeah I mean that was
a prize he was talking that [ __ ] yes you
know so any vault and just like Malcolm
X he evolve like he like if you happy
like we all evolved hopefully hopefully
we all evolved right you know hopefully
we all evolved in like you know and and
and that's why for me like the thing
about the talking [ __ ] like and my book
is oh it's nothing dude this is more of
a serious like got any more serious my
book is all it's almost like [ __ ] talk
it's funny it's about when I fell in
love with Mary Lou Retton 1984 when
people like I'm not reading that
[ __ ] book Charles head
isn't in love with her she's awesome
back exactly I mean I fell in love with
her and tried to make it happen I'm a
Nadia Comaneci guy but yeah so anyway so
but uh whatever you know I'm uh it
weren't an interesting time and you know
whatever